[موسيقى]
الحصاد معكم
الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه احداث تقع
وتتفاعلوا اخرى هذه الصور بدايه من
العاصمه الاكرانيه
تعيش اليوم اجواء الاعياد لكن دون مظاهر
احتفاليه جراء الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
هذه صور من واشنطن للكون الامريكيه بعد ان
تجاوز الجمهوريون امس عقبه انتخاب رئيس
لمجلس النواب
في مواضيع الحصاد
على الرغم من الهدنه المعلنه بشكل احادي
من موسكو القوات الروسيه تعلن تقدمها في
مدينه سوليدار الاستراتيجيه شرقيه
اوكرانيا كيف تنفي وقف الجيش الروسي
عمليته القتاليه وتؤكد استمرار المعارك
وتعلن قصف 24 للقوات الروسيه ومنظومات
صاروخيه
تونس بين تفاقم الازمه السياسيه وتراجع
الوضع الاقتصادي اتحاد الشغل يتهم الرئيس
بالتفرد بالسلطه والتراجع عن مسار الخامس
والعشرين من يوليو ونقابه المتقاعدين تعد
لوقفه احتجاجيه مع وصول التضخم لمستويات
قياسيه سعيد يقيل وزيره التجاره ويتتهم
بعض معارضيه بالتامر على امن الدوله
مجلس النواب الامريكي وانفراج ازمه
الجمهوريين
سبيكم
[تصفيق]
انتخاب ومكار في رئيسا للمجلس تنازلات
لاقصى اليمين وتعهد بمسائله الاداره
الديمقراطيه الحاليه وايضا يهنئ مكارثيه
ويدعوه الى التعامل بمسؤوليه
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا واياكم التفاعلات على ما
كشفه تحقيق برنامج ما خفي اعظم الذي اجراه
تامر الذي بث ليله الماضيه على الجزيره
التحقيق تضمن التفاصيل ومشاهد حصريه تتعلق
ببعض عمليات المقاومه الفلسطينيه في الضفه
الغربيه ضد قوات الاحتلال والمستوطنين كما
عرض لقطات تنشره لاول مره عكس التطور
كتيبه جنين التابعه لسرايا القدس الذراع
العسكريه في الجهاد الاسلامي ومجموعه
عرينا الاسود في نابلس استطلاع رايكم بشان
هذا الموضوع طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
بعد ما كشفه اعظم من حده المواجهه في
الضفه الغربيه مع الاحتلال وبروز عروب
بتسويه المقاتلين في نابلس وجنين كيف
سيؤثر سيؤثر ذلك على شراره المقاومه
85% قالوا ان شراره المقاومه ستصاعد فيما
راى 15% انها ستتراجع
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصات الرقميه
يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو
ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصه الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوريا
تتابعونا في حصاد ايضا
كوسوفو وصربيا هدوء النسبي
[موسيقى]
البدايه مع التطورات في اوكرانيا قبيلا
قضاء هدنه احاديه اعلنتها موسكو جدد الجيش
الروسي اطلاق النار على الرغم من اعلانه
تقدم قوته في مدينه سوليدار الاستراتيجيه
في دنياك كيف من جانبها قالت ان المدينه
مازال تحت سيطرتها نافيه وجود اي هدنه من
الطرف الروسي حيث قالت انه يواصل القتال
في المعارك مضيفه ان القتال مستمر على
محور كما اعلنت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
تصفى 24 تماركوزا للجيش الروسي ومنظومه
صاروخيه
تسمع عنها وقليلا ما تراها فماذا حققت
هدنه الروس يجيبك سريعا تواصل القتال في
محاور عده بشرق اوكرانيا
تحت سيطره قواتها
لا يكتبه الاوكرانيون كثيرا لهدنه الروس
المعلنه من طرف واحد لكنهم يسجلون ما
يرونها خروقات القوات المواليه لموسكو
[موسيقى]
جديد لم يخفي القاده الملون لروسيا عدم
التزامهم باي هدنه بل اعلن بعضهم هذا
الامر صراحه لم يتغير اي شيء لقد استمر
القصف على مواقعنا واستمرت محاولات التقدم
والنجوم من قبل القوات المعاديه
ايفا اتهام معاكس يشير الجيش الروسي الى
القوات الاوكرانيه وصلت قصف التجمعات
السكنيه الى جانب مواقعه في دون باس ومع
ان الروس يعددون بعض انجازاتهم في القتال
كاسقاطه مثلا مسيره في القرن كما يقولون
فانهم يجددون التزامهم بهدنه الساعات
السته والثلاثين
في اوكرانيا منذ منتصف السادس من يناير
وصل نظامك قصف التجمعات السكنيه ومواقع
جيشنا قمنا بالرد ودمرنا جميع الاوكرانيه
بدي يوجعني اذا صح الالتزام الروسي بوقف
احادي لاطلاق النار في عموم اوكرانيا فانه
الاول من نوعه منذ بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا
في فبراير من العام الماضي ما زالت كيف
وحلفائها الغربيون يشككون في الدوافع
الحقيقيه لخطوه الرئيس الروسي تلك
ان الغايه من الهدنه هي سماح للمسيحيين
الاورطوكس بالاحتفال بعيد الميلاد وحضور
قداس العيد لكن الولايات المتحده تعتبرت
القرار الروسي مثيرا للسخريه
وقرا فيه الاتحاد الاوروبي محاوله لكسب
الوقت واعاده تجميع القوات الروسيه وحده
هذا الرجل يدرك ماراميه قراره واحده
في قداس منتصف الليل بكاتدرائيه صممت في
الاساس للقياسره الروس
تنضم الينا من موسكو السيده اولكا كريسناك
استاذت العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه الابحاث
الوطنيه ومن كيف السيد والكسندر ميري شك
رئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في البرلمان
الاوروبي سيد اولكا كيف نفهم ما يقول
الجيش الاوكراني بانه التزام بالهده وفي
نفس الوقت يعلن تقدمه في منطقه سوليدار في
دنياك
اينو ات خالتي
ما اذا كان وقف اطلاق النار قد تم
والخطابات التي تاتي من الجانب الاخر ولكن
المهم ان الرئيس بوتين اعلن عن الهدنه
للاحتفال بعيد الميلاد والفكره هي ان
الشعب الاوكراني طبعا نامل انه في القريب
العاجل سوف يتغير علينا ان نتخطى التحديات
والمصائب على المستوى الثقافي
والاجتماعي وما حصل في هذه الفتره ولذلك
من الاهميه بمكان ان الحظ ان اقتراح
الرئيس بوتن لم يقبل به الجانب الاوكراني
وهنا تكمن المشكله المشكله الثقه وهي
مشكله حول المصالحه المستقبليه بين دولتين
شقيقتيندر
ما قالت القوات الروسيه بانه التزام بهذه
الهدنه
في الحقيقه
بعض اكاذيب واستفزازات الحقيقه هي ان بوتن
يستمر بارتكاب العباده الجماعيه في الخامس
والعشرين من ديسمبر يوم عيد الميلاد قتله
روسيا اكثر من 10 مدنيين وجرحت العشرات
واليوم وحتى يوم امس استمرت روسيا بقصف
المناطق السكنيه المدنيه الاخرانيه
وكنتيجه لهذه الهجمات تعرض عدد كبيرا من
الناس للقتل والاصابه ولذلك وبالرغم من
الاعلان الرسمي عن الهدنه تستمر روسيا
بقتل الاوكرانيين في كل يوم
بغض النظر عن الالتزام سواء كان هناك
التزام ام لا من قبل القوات الروسيه هذه
اول هددنا منذ بدايه الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا هل يمكن ان تؤسس الى مراحل اخرى
ما تفضي الى وقف اطلاق النار لاحقا
يا شاب سعودي
كما سبق وتحدثت الشعب الاوكراني ليس فقط
شعبان نحن نتحدث عن امه واحده وفي الاجزاء
الشرقيه من اوكرانيا والتي يسيطر عليها
الاتحاد الروسي الشعب يحظى بحمايه روسيا
ونتحدث عن حوالي 10 او ايه 10 مليون شخص
لديهم جنسيه روسيه وبالتالي ما من كراهيه
ما من مشاعر كراهيه بين الشعبين نحن نتحدث
عن شعبنا في حقيقه الامر والان نفكر
بمرحله المصالحه على المستوى المجتمعي كيف
يمكننا ان نجري هذه المصالحه مع باقي
اوكرانيا طبعا هذه العمليه العسكريه لا
يمكنها ان تستمر الى ما لا نهايه وسوف تصل
الى نهايتها قريبا او عاجلا ماشيدا
وبالتالي هذه الاعلانات هي طبعا مؤشرات
ايجابيه للدوله الشقيقه ونتوقع المزيد هل
ترون فيها سيد الكسندر مؤشرات ايجابيه كما
تقول السيده اورجا لانها تقول بانه المهم
بان الرئيس بوتين اعلن عن هدنه من طرف
واحد
الا وهو الهزيمه الكامله للامبراطوريه
الروسيه التي ترتكب الاباده وهذا ما يتحدث
عنه
البرلمان الاوروبي وبعض
المسؤولين في اوروبا يتحدثون عن دوله
ارهابيه ولا لانقاذي اوكرانيا يجب هزيمه
روسيا ويجب ان تسحب روسيا كل قواتها من
كامل الاراضي الاوكرانيه بما في ذلك شبه
جزيره القرم المساله الاخرى هي كيفيه
احلال العداله وان يمثل بوتن والمرتبين
امام العداله
الرئيس
واحد من جانب الروسي برز طبعا اتصال بين
بوتين والرئيس التركي اردوغان من جهه
والرئيس الاوكراني ايضا
الرئيس التركي هذا هذا المسار ومحاوله
تركيا لايجاد ارضيه لبدا مفاوضات الى اين
يسير بتقديره
من قبل تركيا ولا ارى اي مشكله في هذا
الخصوص وكما
عبر الرئيس اردوغان هو يود ان يؤدي دور
الوساطه وهو امر ايجابي بنسبه الى القاده
الغربيين انا لا اعتقد ان باستطاعتهم ان
يلعبوا دور الوساطه لان الدول الغربيه
تزود اوكرانيا بالمعدات العسكريه والاسلحه
وفي هذه الحاله على الارجح القاده
الغربيون يودون ان يستمر النزاع حتى اخر
مواطن اوكرانيه وبالتالي ما من الثقه
بالدول الغربيه لانها تؤدي الى اطاله امد
الحرب من خلال تزويد الاوكرانيين بالاسلحه
لربما الثقه اكبر بتركيا والتي لديها
مصلحه بوضع
طبعا الامر لا يتوقف على جهود التركيه
ولكن هي تؤدي جهودا على مستوى الوساطه
للوصول الى مفاوضات سلميه حتى الدول
الغربيه الداعمه لاوكرانيا كانت
قبل وقت مضى بان تكون اكثر ليونه وانفتاحا
للجلوس على طاوله المفاوضات اا بعد هذه
الهدنه من طرف واحد همم هل تعتقد بان
المسار الدبلوماسي ممكن في المرحله
المقبله
يجد ان يستند الى القانون الدولي والقانون
الدولي يفرض او يحكموا السحب القوات
المحتله واعاده الاراضي المحتله الى
اوكرانيا واحلال العداله
وطبعا التعويض عن الاضرار التي لحقتها
روسيا باوكرانيا هذه هي متطلبات القانون
الدولي طبعا الديبلوماسيه ممكنه ولكن من
ضمن حدود القانون الدولي شكرا لكم
اذا تواصل القتال وخير السجال على الهدنه
التي اعلنتها روسيا من جانب واحد في
اوكرانيا ابرز المواقف من هذه الهدنه في
العرض التالي
يوم الخميس قبل عيد الميلاد وفق التقويم
الشرقي اتصلان للرئيس التركي احدهما مع
نظيره الروسي والاخر مع الاوكراني في
اتصاله مع بوتين دعاء اردوغان الى اعلان
وقف اطلاق نار من طرف واحد بعد ساعات
قليله قال الرئيس التركي لنظيره الاوكراني
ان بلاده مستعده للوساطه من اجل سلام دائم
بينك ومسكو في اليوم نفسه اعلن رئيس
الروسي هدنه من طرف واحد لس 36 سنه بدات
الهدنه وفق الاعلان الروسي ظهر الجمعه
وتنتهي منتصفها ليله الاحد رافقتها مطالبه
روسيه لاوكرانيا بوقف اطلاق النار كذلك
ليعيش الناس طقوس العيد رفضته اوكرانيا
لهنه الروسيه راها الرئيس الاوكراني مجرد
خدعه لوقف التقدم الاخرانيه في الميدان
مستشار رئاسه الاوكرانيه اشترط الانسحاب
الروسيه الكامل للموافقه على الهدنه بنفس
زاويه الاخرانيه ينظر الرئيس الامريكي
يقول بايدينا نظيره الروسي تسعى الى متنفس
لا غير لا يبتعد الموقف الاوربي كثيرا
وشرطه يقول مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان الهدنه الروسيه تفتقر
الى المصداقيه ومحاولتها روسيا لتجميل
صورتها الدوليه تواصل القتال في الميدان
وخيم السجال والاتهامات المتبادله على اول
هدنه في حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
التي تم الحديث عنها جاءت بمناسبه اعياد
الميلاد وفق التقويم الشرقي الذي تتبعه
الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه التي تشكل اليوم جزءا
من الجدل اي جدل التوظيف بالحرب هذا
الموضوع وصل نناقشه بعد قليل في فتره في
المتابعه
[موسيقى]
هذا الهدوء الحذر الى شمالي كوسوفو بعد
ثلاثه اسابيع من الاضطرابات بسبب وضع
ناشطين من الاقليه الصربيه حواجز على
الطرقات رفضا لقرارات حكومه بريشتينات
وازالت قوه حفظ السلام الدوليه الحواجز
دون التوصل الى حل سياسي في انتظار وصول
المبعوثين الاوروبي والامريكي الى المنطقه
الاسبوع المقبل لاستئناف في جهود الحوار
بين كوسوفي وصربيا
يلوح هذا الرجل بعلامه التحدي السربيا
وكان الرسوم على الجدار لا تكفي للافصاح
عن هويه المكان هذا هو الجزء الشمالي من
ميتروفيتس تعده كوسوفو جزءا من اراضيها
لكن سكانه السرذ يرفضون الانقياد لحكمتها
لم يتجاوز الاهالي هنا العداوات العرقيه
ولم ينسوا بعد حروبا مضت عليها عقود وقرون
اين حقوق الصلب الذين يعيشون في قصصهم
رزنامه نحن في القرن الحادي والعشرين
وتريدون منا التحويل على امريكا وبريطانيا
والمانيا هل نسيتهم كم بقيه الهند تحت
العبوديه
لا يقبلوا كثيرون هنا بتغيير لوحات
سياراتهم الصربيه الى اخرى كوسفيه يكتفي
اخرون بتغطيه العالم الصربي تجنبا
للمشكلات هذا الشرطي من الاغلبيه الالباني
استقال نحو 500 من زملائه الذين ينتمون
الى الاقليه الصربيه كذلك فعل نواب ووزراء
رفض الصلب المشاركه في انتخابات المحليه
ويطالبون باتحاد ببلدياتهم بصلاحيات
استثنائيه
خاصه من الشرطه في الشمال لتغيير لوحات
السيارات الامور تفاقمت بسبب عدم احراز اي
تقدم في الحوار بين بريشتنا وبلغراد وهذا
اثر في المجتمعات المحليه
التاريخ
الماضي هدات الاوضاع اخيرا لكنه هدوء يخشى
كثيرون ان يكون مؤقتا على الرغم من هدوء
الاوضاع المدنيه في شمال
[موسيقى]
الباطن فهذا الجسر الذي يقسم الى جزئين
الباربي مغلق منذ
وينتظر حلا سياسيا كي يعاد فتحه ويننهي
الحاجه الى مثل هذه القوات الدوليه لحفظ
السلام محمد المدهون الجزيره من بلده
ميتروفيتسا الشماليه كوسوفو
[موسيقى]
الى الازمه في تونس حيث وصف الامين العام
المساعد الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل فيض
حفيظ ازمه الحاليه في تونس بالمعقده
والمركبه واعتبر الامين العام المساعد
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل ان المسار
السياسي الحالي في تونس يمثل ارتدادا
وتراجعا عن مسار الخامس والعشرين من يوليو
بعد تفرد الرئيس قيس سعيد بالحكم وضاف ان
معالجه الحكومه للازمه الاقتصاديه تعتمد
على وصفه بالخيار الليبرالي المتوحش
وتحميل الطبقات الفقيره والضعيفه كلفه
الاسماء وشدد على اتحاد الشغل لا يمكننه
السكوت امامها هذا الوضع
سياسيه لكن اسبابها هو الانقلاب على مسار
25 جويري والتي اقترصها رئيس الجمهوريه
وفعل الفاصل الثماني هو اللي الضبابيه
نتيجه المسار الانفرادي لجسمه رئيس
جمهوريه بعد شهرين بيزار المرسوم عدد 117
واللي جمع فيه السلطات الثلاث بين يديه
للجمهوريه على ان صياغه الدستور لتكون
تشاركيه حتى الحوار العالي كان سوريا قلب
حتى على اقرب الناس له من جهه القانون
الدستوري الضبابيه بيت لحال لما انفرد
بنفسه بصياغه قانون الانتخاب على قياسه
الغي فيه الاجسام الوسيطه والغثيان والغى
فيه كل المكونات السياسيه في البلاد
بجانبه قرر الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد قالته
وزيره التجاره والتنميه الصادرات ووالي
الصفاقس جاء ذلك في بلاغ مقتضب لرئاسه
الجمهوريه دون ذكر الاسباب
الرئيس سعيد قال ان الافعال التي يقوم بها
البعض طرق الى مرتبه التامر على امن
الدوله الداخلي والخارجي تصريحات الرئيس
سعيد جاءت خلال لقائه وزيري العدل
والداخليه وبعد دعوات صريحه لقياده سياسيه
معارضه بتناحي الرئيس وبدعوه مؤسسات
الدوله لعدم الانصياع لاوامر
المشهد السياسي التونسي المتازم لا ينفصل
عن الوضع الاقتصادي المتعثري للبلاد التي
شهدت ارتفاعا قياسيا في معدل التضخم
واستقبلت العام الجديد بتوقعات تنظر
باستمرار حاله الاحتقان الاجتماعي بينما
تمضي الحكومه قدما في حزمه اصلاحات يطالب
بها صندوق النقد الدولي قبل الافراج عن
قرض جديد
دخل تونس العام الجديد 2023 على وقع
ارتفاع في معدل التضخم وصل الى اكثر من
10% وهو الاعلى منذ اربعين عاما ويتوقع
البنك المركزي التونسي وانت تصل النسبه
الى 23% خلال السنه الجايه وتعاني تونس من
مديونيه مرتفعه يعادل حجمها 80% من الناتج
المحلي
والسلطات الان تتفاوض للحصول على قرض جديد
من صندوق النقد الدولي بقيمه مليار و900
مليون دولار تنتظر المؤسسه الماليه لتسليم
الالتزام تونس باصلاحات تشمل مراجعه نظام
الدعم او الغاءه تدريجيا ومراجعه نظام
الضرائب والتحكم في كتله الاجور واعاده
هيكله المؤسسات العموميه المتعثره ذلك ما
جعل اجراءات قانون الماليه الجديد نقطه
خلاف بين الحكومه والنقابات تضمن رفع
ضريبه القيمه المضافه لبعض المهن الحره
مثل المحامين والاطباء من تسعه في المئه
الى 13
% اثار ذلك احتجاج المحامين الذين تطالبوا
نقابتهم بمراجعه قانون الماليه برمته
بدعوه تضمنه اجراءات ضريبيه مجحفه والى
جانبهم تستعد نقابه المتقاعدين لشن حركه
احتجاجيه على تدهور الوضع المعيشي لهذه
الفئه في ظل ارتفاع تكاليف المعيشه بينما
اعلن الاتحاد التونسي للشغل اضرابا واسع
لعمال النقل الجوي والبري والبحري في
الخامس والعشرين والسادس والعشرين من
يناير الجاري احتجاجا على ما يصفه بتهميش
الحكومه للشركات العامه يواجه هؤلاء جميعا
وسائر فئات الشعب التونسي موجه غلاء مسك
الموده الغذائيه وفواتير الكهرباء والماء
ورفع الدعم تدريجيا عن بعض المواد
الاساسيه لا سيما مشتقات الطاقه
ونقش الموضوع من ضيفينا في تونس صالح عطيه
الكاتب الصحفي وابو الحسن اليحياوي الكاتب
والمحل السياسي مرحبا بكما صيد صالح
الانعكاسات المحتمله
لزياده انتقاد الاتحاد التونسي للشغل
لسياسه الرئيس سعيد
مساء الخير
الكرام في كل مكان
اعتقد انه لابد ان نكون واضحين اتحاد
الشغل مرتبك هذه المده بين التصريحات
الفيض اليوم وبين التصريحات قبل يومين في
احدى القنوات التلفزيونيه هنالك
قبل يومين كان يتحدث عن انقلاب 25 يوليو
الاتحاد معه هو يتقطع معه واليوم يتحدث عن
ان هذه 25 يوليو انتهاء وما بعده افسده
وما الى هناك يعني هنالك حاله اربد داخل
الاتحاد شغل بطبيعه الحال لان عكس هذا على
وضع الاتحاد في اداره الحوار الوطني
مستقبل
وفقدت منه ثقته بالنسبه لبعض الاطراف
السياسيه خاصه في المعارضه ان يدير هذا
الحوار وهو بهذه اللغه غير المتشرسه مع
نفسه وغير منصجهما مع المعارضه الاساسي
والاتحاد طبعا لديهم ملفات فساد في على
رئيس الجمهوريه ربما يجري يجري مساومته
وبالتالي هو يخشى يحاول ان عفوا يحاول ان
يجد معادله بين الهروب من هذه المحاسبه ان
صح القول وبين ارضاء الرئيس من ناحيه
الثانيه واستقطاب او الانسجام نسبيا مع
المعارضه التونسيه طبعا المشي على كل
الحبال بهذه الصوره غير ممكن سياسه لابد
ان يختار الاتحاد موقعا معينا اما معارضه
الرئيس بشكل واضح او الذهاب بعيدا مع
الرئيس ايضا بشكل واضح حتى تقدر القوه
السياسيه في تونس ان تذهب معه في الاتجاه
او في هذا الاتجاه سيد حسن كما اشار السيد
صالح بان الاتحاد قال بان ما يقوم بها
الرئيس قيس سعيد الان هو تراجع عن مسار
الخامس والعشرين من يوليو ما دلالات هذا
في هذه المرحله
الحقيقه لنكون واضحين الاتحاد العام
التونسي الشغل تماما مع نفسه وكيل
التصريحين لا يتضادين على العكس من ذلك
الاتحاد ومنذ الخامس في البدايه كان تماما
مع رئيس الجمهوريه في ضروره تغيير
الحاله السياسيه التي كانت سائده قبل
الخامس والعشرين
عند المرسوم 117 تحدث الاتحاد عن ضروره
ايجاد خط الثالث يقطعه
ولكنه طبعا لا يعود الى ما يسمى المنظومه
الرائعه والعشرين
الى ذلك انه جديد هي تلك الرساله التي
تزوجها بها التونسيون من خلال نسبه
المشاركه في الانتخابات التشريعيه السابقه
لاوانينها في شهر ديسمبر هذه الرساله من
فلسطين كان مفادها ان الاملاويه هي
اقتصاديه واجتماعيه بالاساس وهو الملعب
الذي
او في الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
باعتباره كان دائما مدافعا عن طاقه
التونسيين وطاقه العمل والقدره الشرائيه
للعمله وغير ذلك والان طبعا الاتحاد يجد
نفسه في موقف قواه على اعتبار انه يمثل
الراي العام ذي شريحه واسعه من التونسيين
ويقوموا بتوظيف كل ادواته للضغط على رئيس
الجمهوريه من اجل القيام بالاصلاحات
الضروريه وعلى راس هذه الاصلاحات تخيير
اسلوب الخطاب والتغيير طريقه الخطاب مع
بقيه الفاعلين في الساحه السياسيه الاتحاد
العام التونسي للشغل ليس في حاجه الى اي
جسم سياسي مهما كانت قدرته هذا الجسم
السياسي وما كانت تاثير هذا الجسم السياسي
لانه اقدر اذا تحدثنا القدره في حشره
والقدره في التاثير فهو الاخضر من كل جنس
سياسي في في هذه السنوات المتتاليه
بالحديث عن الحج في شارع سيد صالح حتى
الان يعني همم لم تستطع القوى المعارضه
الوقوف في وجه الرئيس قيس سعيد على الاقل
لوقف اجراءاته ما هي اوراق القوى السياسيه
للمعارضه في ظل الدعوه ايضا لتضاهرات
جديده في الايام المقبله
منذ فتره طويله بانه المعارضه الان لرئيس
سعيد معرض همم
في الحقيقه ولا تملك بديلا حتى من حيث
الاشخاص يعني وانا دعوت المعارضه كم مره
الى ان تصدر او ان تخرج شخص ما تقدمه
بديلا لرئيس قيس سعيد حتى ربما تحريجه من
ناحيه سياسيه ويكون ذلك اجابه على الخارج
خصنا الذي يطالب او يدعو او ينتظر هذه
الشخصيه البديله للرئيس سعيد والشارع
التونسي اليوم يتحدث من سيكون بديلا لرئيس
قيس سعيد في صوره همم خروجه من السلطه قبل
نهايه عهدته نحن امام هذا الماء اسقف في
الحقيقه غير المشروع لدى رئيس الجمهوريه
غياب مشروع للاتحاد عن تونس للشغل على عكس
ما تحدث عنه استاذ يحيى وغير مشروع لدى
المعارضه التونسيه لدينا ازنتين مركبتين
معقدتين ازمه المشروع بالنسبه لكل الاطراف
من ناحيه وازمه قد كل الاطراف في في بعضها
البعض وازوا ايضا خلقها رئيس الجمهوريه
بهذا الدستور الجديد بهذا الاستفتاء بهذه
الانتخابات الفاشله لحد الان واستمرار
واصمراره على الاستمرار في هذا النهج
القضيه ليست قضيه قدير خطاب بالنسبه لرئيس
الجمهوريه كما يتحدث الاستاذ اليحيوي
القضيه قضيه سياسات القضيه قضيه نمط
التنموي القضيه قضيه اجتماعي ايضا القضيه
قضيه سياسيه اقتصاديه واجتماعيه وثقافيه
وايضا خيارات سياسيه نحن لسنا امام هذا
مطلقا والا حد لا يطالب فقط في تقدير
بمعنى تغيير الخطاب يطالب بسياسات وانا لا
اتفق مع الاتحاد بان اتجاه انه حكومه
التجاري بيرالي متوحش لانه ليس لديها لا
خيارا لنيبراليا ولا متوحشه نحن امام
استحقاقات واصلاحات من صندوق النقد الدولي
بالنظر للوضع الهش في تونس الاقتصاديه
والماليه وبالتالي نحن مجتهدون لهذه
الصندوق اما ان نذهب اليه مجتمعون وياه
وبمشروع سياسي يضمن استقرار ويضمن تيمومه
الانتقال الديمقراطيه في تونس واما ان
نبقى مشتين كمعارضه وكصوله
جدا جدا
سيد حسن انت قلت ان هناك معطى جديد
بالنسبه للاتحاد وهو الوضع الاقتصادي
المازوم كيف يتعامل الرئيس قيس سعيد مع
التهديدات المتواتره
النقابيه لمواجهه قررته في الشارع
مع الاستاذ صالح
ان يتحدث ان الاتحاد تحدث عن خيار ثالث
ولكنه لم يتمكن من تاسيس او تقديم هذا
الخيار الثالث بالاضافه الى ذلك احد اهم
نقاط قوه الرئيس سعيد هي هذه المعارضه
بشكلها وبشخوطها الان هل ان الرئيس السيسي
صحيح
الشغل اعتد انه لا يمكن مواجهه كل الخصوم
في نفس الوقت يعني المعارضه السياسيه
الشخصيه السياسيه والمنظمات وعلى راسها
اتحاد الشغل ولذلك راينا بعض المؤشرات ان
الرئيس السيسي سعيد يحاول احداث تغيير ناس
صلبه الحكومه وبالتالي تغيير ماء السياسات
التجاره
الحاليه والتي قال شانها شان
الشخصيه الاخرى داخل هذه الحكومه فشلت في
اداره بعض الملفات وزاره التجاره تعنى
بالملفات التي تمسه مباشره المواطن
التونسي في ما يتعلق بالمواد الاساسيه
فيما يتعلق بالقدره الشرائيه والى غير ذلك
قد تكون هذه الاقاله هي رساله غزل يرسلها
الرئيس قيس سعيد نحو اتحاد الشغل من اجل
الجلوس اليه والتفاوض مره اخرى حتى يهرب
من شبه حسين مدني قد يعلنه الاتحاد العام
التونسي الشغل بالاضراب العام وبخير ذلك
الذي يمكن ان يسبب شلل للدوله ويمكن ان
يزيد من صعوبه همم الرئيس في اداره الشؤون
الداخليه
مثلا شكرا لكما بالحسن الاحياوي صالح عطيه
[موسيقى]
مطرقه رئيس مجلس النواب بعد ازمه لم
تشهدها الولايات المتحده منذ اكثر من 150
عاما انتخب مجلس النواب الامريكي رئيسا
جديدا له يحصل على مئتين وسته عشر صوت
جمهوريه بعد ان قدم تنازلات لنوادي اقصى
اليمين في حسبه وتعاهد مكان في بعد
انتخابه بتجاوز الخلافات الداخليه بين
الجمهوريين ومسائله اداره وايضا بجانبه
الرئيس الامريكي
[تصفيق]
معركه طاحنه داخل البيت الجمهوري امتدت
فصولها لمده اربعه ايام وعلى مدى 15 جوله
تصويت وفي لحظه من اللحظات توقف مستقبل
مقارنه على عضو جمهوري واحد وكاد المشهد
ان ولا من الفوز الى مشاجره داخل احد اهم
مفاصل الحكم في الولايات المتحده
لم ياتي دون تنازلات لمجموعه متعمده من
اقصى يمين حزبه ابرزها تنازل قد يضعف منصب
رئيس المجلس كالسماح لمشرع واحد بالتقدم
لحجب الثقه عنه تنازلات اخرى طالت الانفاق
الحكوميه ورفع سقف الدين وقد تنظر بمواجهه
مستقبليه تهدد باغلاق حكوميه
من افغانستان
الى استخدام
سياسييا سنستخدم موقعنا في اصدار
الاستدعاءات والرقابه على الانفاق علينا
تامين حضورنا واعاده امريكا الى الطريق
الصحيح
الجمهوريون في مجلس النواب للرئيس
الامريكي
من صداع فقد ابدى استعداده للتعاون مع هذه
القياده الجديده مثله مثل زعيم الاقليات
الديمقراطيه حكيم جافريز لكن جافريز ذكرا
ايضا بان حزبه لن يهادنا على مبادئه
قبل حكم الفرد المطلق والخير قبل التعصب
الاعمى والدستور قبل الطائفيه
والديمقراطيه قبل الغاء والفرص الاقتصاديه
قبل
التطرفين من اهميه ما حدث يبرز التساؤل عن
ما اذا كان شلل الايام الماضيه هو من
تجليات الديمقراطيه الامريكيه ام انه
اختلال في عملها
الان هو اننا نمضي قدما كبلد لكن منقسمين
لان لدينا كونجرسون قسم واغلبيه ضيقه في
مجلس النواب وهذا لا يصب في مصلحتهم في
ممارسه السلطتهم في الحكم الجمهوريون مثل
التحقيقات قبل اي شيء اخر وظيفه اولئك
الاشخاص هي سن التشريعات وهذا تخلل عن
مهامهم وليس جيدا لمستقبل الحزن
ستدخل الايام الماضيه سجل تاريخ الامريكي
دون شك لكن قد يكون المشهد الذي لن ينسى
هو توقف عمليه التصويت على صوت مشرع واحد
مشهد ينظر بان طريق المصاعب لم ينتهي بل
بدا للتوب بسنه كويك الجزيره واشنطن
والحكومه في جامعه جورج
روفسر كيف ترى التنازلات التي قدمها
مكارثي لمجموعه من حزبه الحسبه الجمهوري
مقابل انتخابه رئيسا لمجلس النواه
تحدث تحدث
الموقع الذي اراد لاكثر من عقدا ان يكون
فيه والاهم سوف يكونوا من السهوله بنسبه
الى الجمهوريين ان يضع حدا لرئاسته لمجلس
النواب احد الاعضاء يمكنه ان يطرح الثقه
وسوف يتعين عليه ان يقوم بما قام به يوم
امس مجددا لكي يكسب الثقه وما الذي دفع
الحزب الجمهوري الى هذا الخيار واضعاف
بالتالي
مركز رئيس مجلس النواب الذي هو تابع لحزب
الجمهوري بتقديره
الاشخاص الذين دفعوا به بهذا الاتجاههم من
المتطرفين الذين لا يودون ان يقوموا
بالعمل التشريعي هناك تعاونا التقليديا في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وشاهدناه
رئاسه كان لديها اكثريه مشابهه ولكنها
تواصلت مع الجمهوريين لانها كانت بحاجه
اليهم الاشخاص الذين يردون ان يضعف الموقع
لا يودون التواصل وصفقات مع الديمقراطيين
والتشريع من قبل الحذبان يودون تغييرا
رديكالا في الحكومه الانقسام الذي برز في
الحزب الجمهوري منذ خروج الرئيس دونالد
ترامب من البيت الابيض والذي تجلى الان في
هذه الانتخابات
رئيسا لمجلس النواب ما انعكاساته المحتمله
على ممارسه الحزب وحياته وسياسته في
الكونجرس الامريكي بتقديرك بروفيسور
الحكوميه في اكتوبر او في نوفمبر الاحتمال
يرتفع والنقطه الاهم نتحدث عن سقف الدين
الامريكي اذا ما لم يصوتوا لرفع سقف
الدينا سوف يكون هناك ازمه ماليه دوليه
المره الاخيره التي
قاموا بالعمل فيها على هذا المجال خسرنا
المليارات حوالي 40 مليار دولار في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذه الازمه
المرتبطه بالدين الامريكي يمكن ان تكون
كارثيه ليس فقط الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بالاسواق الماليه في كل مكان
تعهد
بمسائله اداره الرئيس جو بيدن ما الذي
تتوقعه في هذا المسار
وين
الامور بالنسبه الى كل
الجمهوريين
يتفقون على نقطه واحده سوف يحققون
وابنه
واخيه سوف يكون هناك تحقيق حول الانسحاب
من افغانستان وكما تعرفون في المشاهدون
الانسحاب تم بطريقه سيئه ومتسرعه وادى ذلك
الى مقتل عدد كبير من الناس سوف يكون هناك
تحقيقات منها المبرر كهذا التحقيق ولكن
هناك النظريات مؤامره في الطرف الاخر ويجد
العمل عليها شكرا لك
نعود الى اوكرانيا ولكن ليس من باب
المعارك وانما من الاعياد التي تعيشها هذه
الايام حيث يحل اول عيد ميلاد حسب التقويم
الارثوذكسي الشرقي هناك وسط جدل متصاعد
بشان تحديد موعد في ظل ارتفاع الاصوات
المطالبه باعتماده يوم الخامس والعشرين من
ديسمبر وفق التقويم الغربي بدلا من السابع
من يناير وفق التقويم الشرقي وقد اثار
الامر حفيظه البطريركيه في موسكو والكنائس
التي تزال تابعه لها في اوكرانيا واعتبرت
هذه الاصوات ولا اعتبرت هذه الاصوات خروجا
عن المذهب الارثوذكسي
دون كهرباء وفي مراسم التسمت بالبساطه
احتفل الاوكرانيون من الارثوذكس بعيد
الميلاد
[موسيقى]
كما هي الحال في المذاهب الاخرى اميره
الشموع على امل ان يحل السلام في عيد شهد
خلافا بين كنائس المذهب الواحد في البلاد
بشان موعده
مذهب ومرجعيه ثاني للارثوذكس في اوكرانيا
واحده في كيف والاخرى في موسكو
منذ عده سنوات دعت مرجعيه وكيف الى تغيير
موعد العيد الى يوم 25 من ديسمبر الامر
الذي اثار حفيظه البطريركيه موسكو التي
تعتمد السابع من يناير موعد للعيد
يجب ان لا نبقى رهينه للكنيسه في موسكو
التي شاركت في التحريض والقتل ضدنا
الاحتفاله بالعيد ايا كان التوقيت في
اجواء الحرب يجعلك تحس بشعر غريب كيف لنا
الاحتفال تحت القصف والقذائف حتى من هو
الان في مكان امن لا يعرفون ان كان احد من
احد سيستطيع الاحتفال او انه سيبقى على
قيد الحياه يوم العيد
على الرغم من عدم وجود مظاهر الاحتفال في
الشوارع والساحات العامه
فان البعض اقاموا طقوس العيد
[موسيقى]
في بيت يضم عددا من العائلات كلها نازحه
بدا ان بهجه العيد اتخذت لنفسها مكان هنا
الهدف هو التفكير في القادم كما يقولون
وكل الاماني ستكون معقوده على انتهاء
الحرب
ان نكون متفائلين وايجابيين الكل محتاج
هنا للتنفيذ عن الالم والتوتر والخوف من
المستقبل الغامض لكن لا باس من بعض الفرح
واستعاده ذكريات العيد الجميله
اعلنت موسكو هندا من جانب واحد لكن كيف
رفضت ذلك وقالت ان روسيا تريد الظهور
بمظهر الراغب في السلام وهي التي قصفت
العشرات من دور العباده
في تغيير موعد الاحتفال بعيد الميلاد
تعبيرا عن رفضهم لسلطه وسياسه الكنيسه
روسيه التي يعتبرونها معاديه لبلادهم
بينما لا يزال اخرنا موالينا للكنيسه في
موسكو خلاف يعمل الكثيرون هنا لا يؤثر على
جوهر العيد المتمثل بالحفاظ على الروابط
العائليه التي يقوم عليها المجتمع
الاوكراني عمر الحاج الجزيره من مدينه
الحرب في اوكرانيا اثير فيها جدلوا دور
الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه الروسيه بعد اتهامات
طالت الرئيس الروسي فلاديمر بوتن بتوظيفها
في الحرب ولكن ما الرابط بين البلدين في
هذا الامر منذ بدايات القرن السابع عشر
كانت اوكرانيا منضويه تحت سقف الكنيسه
الارثوذكسيه الروسيه واستمر ذلك حتى عام
1992 اي بعد انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي حيث
استعاده دول الاتحاد السوفيتي سابقا
استقلالها لتحظه بذلك الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه
باستقلال تام في اداره شؤونها مع الحفاظ
على التبعيه الرسميه لموسكو لكن الاخيره
اعتبرته انشقاقا على اي حال مرحله
الابتعاد الثانيه كانت ما بين 2000 و18
و2,000 و2019 حيث انشق قسم من الكنيسه
الارثوذكسيه الاوكرانيه عن موسكو بعد ضمها
شبه جزيره القرم فيما وصف بانشقاق تاريخي
وبعد ثلاثه اشهر من انطلاق الحرب العام
الماضي اعلنت الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه
الاوكرانيه التابعه لروسيا قطع علاقاتها
ببطريتكيه موسكو واستقلالها بشكل تام
موسكو احاله القرار الى ضغوط تعرضت لها
الكنيسه الاوكرانيه ولقطع طريق العوده
ولتوحيد قطبي الكنيسه في اوكرانيا اعلن
الرئيسكي مشروع قانون يحضر عمل اي منظمه
دينيه تابعه لروسيا
لماذا يتهم الرئيس الروسي فيلاديمير بوتين
باليتهم بتوظيف الكنيسه في الحرب وما
دورها يرى مراقبون ان بوتين منح الكنيسه
نفوذا كبيرا عام 2009 عندما اعاد
ممتلكاتها المصادره ابانه الحقبه الشيعيه
ومع ضم روسيا لشبه جزيره القرن باركت
البطريركيه الروسيه الخطوه وهو ما احرج
الكنيسه الاوكرانيه التابعه لبطريركيه
موسكو دفعها لاعلان استقلالها التام كما
اشرنا منذ قليل في حرب اوكرانيا تداخل
الشؤون الدينيه بالعمليه العسكريه في
ارسال موسكو عشرات الكهنه الى جبهه القتال
لدعم الجنود الروس وفيما بدا اطفاءا
لعناوين مقدس على الحرب عبر رئيس الكنيسه
الارثوذكسيه الروسيه البطريل عن دعمه
للاذاعه واكد الدعم لمن وصفهم بالاخوه
الموالينا لروسيا في شرق اوكرانيا الذين
رفضوا القيم الغربيه على حد تعبيره في
المقابل لا يغيب الاوكرانيون عن الاشارات
الدينيه في النزاع مع روسيا فالرئيس
الاوكرانيا السابق بتروبريشنكا اكد وجود
رابط مباشر بين الاستقلال الديني والسياسي
حينما قال عام 2018 ان استقلال كنيسه
اوكرانيا جزء من سياسات اكياف المؤيده
لاوروبا والمواليات لاوكرانيا
من لندن البروفيسور مارتن استاذ علم
اجتماع الاديان في جامعه
الدين والدوله
بروفيسر مرحبا بك على ضوء الاتهامات التي
توجه للرئيس بوتن باستغلال الكنيسه ما مدى
همم يعني همم اذا صح التعبير توظيف الرئيس
بوتن الكنيسه في حربه الخارجيه لاسيما في
اوكرانيا
رئيس بوتن يستخدم كل الموارد المتاحه
لترسيخ في قوته وتعزيز قوته وتبرير افعاله
في اوكرانيا اذا ما تحدثنا عن الملف
الاوكراني على وجه الخصوص ونحن نعرف بكل
تاكيد ان الكنيسه لها تاثير في المجتمع
اما بالنسبه الى مساله استغلال
الكنيسه نحن نتحدث عن
طريقه وحيده او محدده
لاستعمال هذا الوجه
في في حرب هذا الوجه في علاقته مع الكنيسه
اعتقد ان العلاقه هي متبادله الكنيسه
الارثوذكسيه الروسيه تدعم الغزو لاوكرانيا
والبطريرك كاريل اعرض عن موقفا لصالح
بوتين ودعم للحرب في سبتمبر وصل الى حد
القول ان كل روسي يساهم في الحرب ويقاتل
في الحرب الى جانب القضيه الروسيه والى
جانب القوات الروسيه هو يقاتل في سبيل
الدوله الام في سبيل الوطن
والسوف همم تغفر له خطاياه وطبعا نحن
نتحدث عن تصريحا قويا همم للغايه وهيعطي
الصبغه الدينيه والتبرير الدينيه لهذه
الحرب وبالتالي يعتقدوا ان هذه العلاقه هي
متبادله واعتقد ان الكنيسه هي مسؤوله عن
موقفها بالنسبه الى اوكرانيا وطبعا تجاه
الرئيس بوتين وبالنسبه الى النخبه
السياسيه
الى اي حد ايضا يعتبر الانفصال الكنسي
الاوكراني هو سياسي ايضا في هذه المرحله
اكشن اكشن
في حقيقه الامر على المستوى الارثوذكسي في
اوكرانيا نتحدث عن كنيستين اساسيتين على
مستوى اوكرانيا طبعا في المذهب الارثوذكسي
هناك الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه في
اوكرانيا والبطريقيه في موسكو هناك بعض
السياسي طبعا ولكن الامر لا يتوقف فقط عند
الوجه السياسي حيث اننا نتحدث عن تعريف
الامه
وتعريف الوطن والدوله في التقليدي والطقوص
الارثوذكسيه طقوس المسيحيه الشرقيه
التقليديه كل دوله
لديها كنيسه خاصه بها هذا تقليد مشرقيا
همم مسيحي وبالتالي في هذا السياق ان
استقلال الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه الاوكرانيه
يمكن ان يندرج في هذا
السياق طبعا اقول ان هناك بعدا السياسيه
في هذا الانقسام بين الكنيستين الاساسيتين
في اوكرانيا ولكنه لا يتوقف عند الوجه
السياسي فقط
لو سمحت اجابه بدقيقه واحده ااه هل من
تاثيرات او تداعيات محتمله لهذا الانفصال
على النسيج همم التاريخ
المشرق بين روسيا واوكرانيا
اريد
انقسام بين الكنيستين
الاوكرانيه والروسيه هل له تداعيات محتمله
على النسيج الارثوذوكسي التاريخي بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا بدقيقه واحده لو سمحت
ضد الغزو الروسي وعبرته عن موقفا ضد الغزو
الروسي في هذه
الحاله ليس هناك من تداعيات على هذا
المستوى في هذه الزاويه في نهايه المطاف
سوف
تقرر هذه النقطه نتيجه الحرب والعلاقه بين
الحكومتين الحكومه الاوكرانيه والحكومه
الروسيه
تداعيات خطيره او اساسيه على البلدين
العكس شكرا في لندن
امراه اشترن استاذ علم الاجتماع الاديان
في جامعه شكرا لك
في هذا نصل الى نهايه الحصاد شكرا لكم على
حسن متابعه الى اللقاء بامانه
[موسيقى]